Benson do you want to read this cash app
add as share yeah this show is brought
up like a shirt the number one findings
on the app store
cash app there's a simplest way to see
and receive money and especially by new
you all your friends and your friends
all you chickenshit friends how do you
use the cash app warning every much more
interested sheriff I could talk to
bendin for a second how you use the
Kasia another day I sent my friend money
second avoid going to our baby shower I
said here's a hundred bucks I can't make
it like in lieu of my presence I said
look I'm gonna show you some money
that's crazy
I think that works out great pin the
diaper on your unborn baby catch up
also there easier is we're driving
you're gonna you're selling me snake oil
in the stock market with their investing
feature with cash app you can instantly
invest in any stock as little as one
dollar did you know the brokerage
services are provided by cash app
investing a subsidiary square and member
opposite well now you do as always when
you sign up for cash and use the promo
code Whitney not only will you instantly
receive ten dollars but cash app will
also donate ten dollars to The Trevor
Project an organization provides
protective services to LGBTQ and a plus
right youth across America square don't
forget the promo code Whitney and then
download Kasia from the App Store tada
[Music]
Bobby this is kind of amazing to watch
I've known you for so long how we
started
yeah we're let start now okay we're
starting can I ask a question first yes
based on your comedy meter right am i
one of the greatest comedians in the
planet Earth as well I think thank you
as well Bobby is mocking me and he's
doing an inside do you want to do this I
mean do you I don't think he's great
this is the show I think this is the
episode where I officially leave the
business of show yeah because podcasts
I'm realizing you talk for 2-3 hours
you're gonna I talk so much shit yeah
and I haven't been doing this that long
and it's been hard for me to not
completely burn every Bridge in
Hollywood this is the episode where I
just set it all on fire
I think we should be careful though okay
I think we should be careful because I
think that you still we still both we're
not like Joe Rogan Joe Rogan close the
door yeah it feels
echoey or is that just you something I
can't even hear myself yeah the only
problem and yeah you seem echoey to me
yeah yeah I can't hear myself either
he's not the way I did it no I don't
know hello bent on this equipment yeah I
can't really where do you shoot the bad
friend Oh God in the ghetto where why on
Colfax I let Andrew Santino do it he has
no sense of style
Lupin's clothing it's all gap right he's
such a Silicon Valley billionaire right
right in terms of his can you turn up my
mic a little bit more so you'd like to
hear your headphone you like to hear
yourself in the headphones just a little
bit can I hear something yeah okay
yeah did you do it I don't think that
was so close to the mic is that okay
this is good
that's fine perfect can I hear is
everything good now everything's good
are we we're going keep all that in oh I
like all that people like flaws I'd like
it to be real now what are you doing now
you're just moving around okay well
what's saying is is that you know so you
know Joe Rogan I talked to me the other
night he was like fuck Hollywood we were
doing our own thing yes and we can make
our own money by doing this but there is
still a part of me that still wants to
still work yeah in in you know cuz I
like acting and I like doing other
things but what I love about this is
first of all I've been close I'm now
closer to you guys in terms of
relationship wise this is actually what
it took for people like us to hang out
with our own friends yeah it's sad and
when I see friends of ours at the Comedy
Store and we start talking I'm always
like is anyone getting this you know
well you would also like my relationship
of the comics were usually like get
offstage some will go good set I go see
you and that's it mm-hmm and you know
and now it's like there's calls being
made and you know I mean I know we're
all using shit that's exactly what we're
doing we're just using each other but
yes prostituting yeah I think that
though people like us who have I don't
think intimacy issues but at least just
kind of like it's hard for us to get
close to people being on a podcast is a
way to really connect with someone
emotionally with the safety of a bunch
of strangers listening yes so we can
feel like we're performing a little bit
which is our natural inclination anyway
and not feel corny yes I prefer it to as
for stew over stand-up in a sense
because um I'm not waiting for a laugh
yeah right I can just be I can let
things breathe and hair and
I'm not a lot of things I'm not trying
to be funny on these I'm just want to
just share my point of view yeah or how
I feel about certain things so that's
what I like to get personal and deeper
sometimes and this is the best format
really to be honest with you that's why
I didn't want to start a podcast for a
long time so I was like I don't want to
just be eating shit for two and a half
hours I gotta feel like I'm bombing you
know whatever II was like no it's just a
conversation and I was like no no one's
gonna like me - who would want to listen
to me have a conversation like I just my
self-esteem was so low it just never
occurred to me that some want to hear me
talk for three hours yeah the worst is
when you're like doing a show like
you're acting and you're like sometimes
I'm on magnum p.i and did this they
write it funny for me yeah but I know
something super funny and I say it and
then you know no one laughs because you
know there because it's not their stroke
is just their joke it's your also they
can't laugh because they can't big shake
because they're not allowed to disrupt
in your head you're like yeah still a
part of me that's like I'm eating it I
need I need the camera gotta go oh that
just ruined the tape because I shove the
camera and then I'm like great I just
did my job and unusable page you can
hear this just like somebody covering
the mouth right like that scripts
personal yeah I am the world's like I
but if people do laughs I don't trust it
either I'm like you're just doing that
so we move on or you're just turning me
feel good I such deep impostor syndrome
then even when I do get the laugh I want
I'm like ah you're just doing that cuz
you have to it's just can't win you know
I also don't like about acting is is
that like when they do the other
person's coverage right like when
they're doing their coverage I'm in I
might have my line yes and I'm doing it
even though that the camera is not on me
I'm trying to help them but then on my
coverage they're texting they're reading
the fucking thing yeah sometimes they're
not there have you ever had a famous
actor put a tennis ball on a stick and
you act kind of small which sometimes
honestly yeah
a really famous actor looking at you do
your three takes when they're not even
on camera they want to get the fuck out
of there
my work is gonna be worse because I'm
like just rushing you know I mean I'd
actually rather act with a fuckin
volleyball with a smiley face on it or
like a post-it notes at least I don't
feel rushed yeah you know yeah I liked
it when I did this I've never been
around a lot of big people but one time
you have to deprecate before almost
every factual sentence you say I know
you just observe that mhm
is it me or just in comics or just me
specifically that is you specifically
and I think that's what I fuckin hate
about you fuck you you fuckin your part
you're gonna fucking do this now bitch
you fucking asshole you fuck you let me
say something
this is this the best feeling to come
it's the most effective yes don't Rob
yourself of calls me out on things like
I'll be like one thing you were at the
comedy store ones it's just like I just
you know I just can't hold on hold on
we're gonna set this story up for real
because the story comes up a lot people
email me about it people DM me about it
this has become like kind of a what has
like a mythical legendary story yeah
tell your side of the story and then
I'll tell why I'm gonna tell you the
truth right and then the truth will be
there and then I will tell you the nice
room that's the women get to have their
own truths now this is the story okay
the story is that I have a tendency I
used to have this tendency to do okay on
stage or good but still I perceived it
to be bad and then I go backstage and I
start telling everyone that it was a bad
set mm-hmm
what did you do before your sets I don't
know what do you mean
what do mean uh-huh up and down before
your sets either yeah I do okay
you put that deadlock who doesn't do
that and like cursing yourself yeah I do
that yeah yeah yeah yeah muttering that
you're about to eat you know Mom yeah
yeah yeah yeah I did that the other
night I Joe Rogan was before me well
that I was pacing back there going I
gotta follow this guy following Rogan
and Joey Diaz that's a different story
okay well thank you I had to follow Joey
Diaz goodnight I was stretching in the
hallway I was like warming up my hammies
let's just grow wine just a little bit
because I was unable to approach it
we'll go back to this in a second I want
to say that um Whitney Cummings is
bringing Martin Lawrence on stage so
okay this is honestly I've been in
comedy for over 20 years and I've never
like held the side of my body also in
just in kind of a disgust and trembling
and just I can't would believe what I
just witnessed and here's the other
thing I'm gonna say I have in my 15 14
years of comedy I have never had Bobby
bring me on stage stay on stage bring
someone up come off and him still be
there yeah you normally go right home I
go home yeah I came offstage you were
there yeah yeah yeah yeah so I this is
what wouldn't did all right yeah so
Whitney is bringing Martin Lawrence and
let me just say something about my let
me just say something about Martin
Lawrence right Martin Lawrence is a
fuckin comedy legend Martin top my
favorite sitcom number one of the in my
opinion with you season three especially
genius because him and his co-star
wouldn't talk in real life so they were
had different amazing once you learn all
the lore about it yeah in the fall
incredible he's writing three parts all
hilarious great legend and movies as
well Martin so watch it have the DVDs to
the writers but Whitney brings him up
by saying don't know he's getting called
up don't know he's coming up he's a
surprise guest so I was a little flood
okay I want to just argue that
whoa quick okay on the line up when it
says surprise fest right it's only him I
thought it was gonna be Chapelle cuz he
was in the belly beam I never he's never
in slaughtered as a surprise guest he's
oh he just shows up and goes off okay
right and you know that you knew it was
that's crazy
death lies and don't fucking try to lie
to me on your podcast and he's great and
he's a nice guy I used to open for
Martin and I am NOT making fun of him or
anything but she says Ike this is the
greatest comedian of all time I went
into I said one of the you heard that
yeah did you hear me laugh I want like
us happened and then I got hi Ghazi so I
think he he's been doing stand-up for a
while that's he listened he I was trying
to give and he was great
he just has the number one movie in the
world fast in the boys Mustang yeah you
know Cigna poor nights whatever it's
called yeah and she's the number one
movie and I'm what else am I gonna I
mean because it's reserved for Chris
Rock is reserved for here's what argue
about that those comics usually don't
like it when you do that that's true
they don't like it cuz they're like bill
burr whenever I was like he's the best
comic working or whatever he's like
please don't do that he could also be
one of the greatest who knows it
definitely took his perception it
definitely scratched it a wound in you
[Laughter]
oh you think that thing something really
pissed you off about that I'll tell you
what pisses me off about it and is is
that I I know him yeah and he is one of
those guys that like sometimes I'll say
hello
and he's hello who the plot thickens he
says no idea who I am right I bring him
on stage he's aloof
Yeah right that sometimes the other day
he was leaning against the wall and I
loved his road manager Michael if you're
listening Michael I'm we're not bagging
on your boy he's one of the biggest
comics of all time and this is just
you're not listening to this anyway I'm
not Gary Owen if I was Gary Owen he will
listen but yeah he the other night he
was sitting again I get bad boys just
came out yeah she hit and literally this
closer says I cook hi Martin and he
literally saw right through me like I
was translucent but here's what I'll say
he's not going on stage every night like
we are at Swanson and here's what I
think I this is where I get too anxious
and I overcompensate and I get people
pleasee and my codependents comes out
because I go like holy fuck like this is
a guy I watched when I was a kid before
the idea even being a comedian that
person is like a huge legend to me I
have not caught up on where people are
and I still am totally in awe and I
still see myself as an open mic er so
you know what you're right and let's
just we might even I mean let's take it
back know what I don't apologize I want
to apologize and I also want to take it
back you know by you saying he's one of
the greatest comedians of all time and I
know I made fun of you about it
Oh for let relentlessly for a bunch I
want to take it back and go you know
what he could quite possibly be number
one and number two he is one of the last
comics that has that allure that you
would you know that Eddie Murphy had
back in the day here's what I'll say
like I think that when you watch these
guys they get so famous in movies and I
think a lot of people I have to be
honest with you I don't know this is
probably just me projecting because I
took like a year off stand-up when I was
making something yeah and then people
knew me as an actress and not a stand-up
and then I came back to doing stand-up
and people like what she does stand it
you're like wait no that's my number one
thing so I think I probably project onto
him of PEEP
just think of him as a movie star with
someone saw Martin Lawrence do stand-up
right and I was like he probably is like
you know as a stand-up you never get to
coast on your fame if anything the bar
is even higher so I was just turn like
build up the that's a very good that's
good very good but the point is this
that's a very good point because Martin
Lawrence needs me yes but the point is
also is that we know we covet what we
see like Buffalo Bill yeah you know we
you know we you know we see each other
so much that we think that we were
comics yeah yeah yeah because we're in
the trenches so much and when sometimes
when you see a visitor yeah maybe it
that is what kind of someone who was
kind of an outsider and isn't there
every night and I would project oh he
thinks he's above having to work out
every day yeah or something like that
yeah it's also he's so famous leaving
his house is probably fucking nightmare
yeah yeah but who would and you know
this isn't about if someone's gonna this
is gonna hurt someone's feelings
who would you say the best working comic
is today oh the hardest-working best
what I mean the best is just it can be
one of four people who are the booster
to me who are the funniest got oh my god
why would you even name one name one I'm
trying to even think you know what I
honestly just try to prove a point I
honestly think that for me uh-huh who I
would watch every time that he would
perform atop no Jessel deck oh wow yes
and here's the irony agree I would never
say that about him even though I believe
it why because it's just lies you know
what I mean because he's there every
night it would just be like corny yeah
do you like one of the best comedians
working he would just be like ill but
for me
why Jeselnik is because of the fact that
um all he does is and they're brilliant
but he's sweaty two switches a lot yeah
and I always in new jokes I always try
to find in my mind what the switch is
gonna be yep and usually I can't find it
a surprise
yeah is that he's so good at that or he
just even me knowing that that's what
his style is yeah
his punchlines are various surprising
it's a truth punch it's a true punch
yeah oh fuck that's a great angle I
didn't see that coming that kind of
thing and he also and this is I think
doing a podcast is helping me work this
muscle because it's not a muscle that I
have at all he has a patience to let
things get quiet for so fucking long
like watching an ice skater we were like
oh you better land this behind ya and
build so much tension so few comics do
that anymore because I boom boom you
just want to do like machine gun Joe let
me ask you listen never point at me in
front of let me fuckin ask you who's a
comic that has a lot of hype who's doing
very well but you don't think it's funny
I mean I I'm actually been excited about
this yeah because you you are you hit a
new gear psychologically in the last six
months that I can feel and I think it's
because you had a family tragedy I had a
similar one where you give less fucks
yeah I feel like you're ready to name
names and burn fuckin bridges yeah I
just do one of your episodes you guys
trashed every number one this is why
this is such a popular podcast like just
throwing grenades left and right but my
guess is it would be like a youtuber
that I don't understand right I don't
understand a lot of these YouTube people
that Benton chose me I don't know I
don't get why it's funny
I don't you know I mean these people
have 20 million followers that are doing
these corny ass sketches like I don't
get that you know it's funny that you
say that because I don't eat as well but
um you know you've always been to me in
my person you're gonna hate what I say
okay but I always think that you're one
of the elitists in comedy you're a part
of the elite crowd what does that mean
well you are you God why am I gonna hate
that I love that yeah I don't really do
really yeah I I look at you like you
know you know how you see I see you know
a guy like that is John Mulaney
oh well yeah to me John Mulaney is a
part of that elite crowd I feel like you
are too I mean a part of that but what
is that based on cuz you are well thank
you because it's like well look at this
house dismantled a lot of racial
stereotype cannot figure out the numbers
to Mikey
what was my point though well I think
the main point we're talking about it's
just sort of like if someone's in your
grade stand up does that make sense yeah
yeah like it's you're not gonna
acknowledge that they're the greatest
cuz they're just your friends yeah you
know I mean I think it's weird that we
you know comedians are so few of us
respectively two other jobs and it's
weird to think that someone you came up
with is all of a sudden like in the best
no I know what my point was I know what
my point was so you know but for me I
feel like I'm now getting toward that
your area mm-hmm hundred yeah I feel it
you know I mean but for a very long time
when you had your show Whitney because I
know specifically excited addition for
your show in that time period I also
want to talk about that because you do
lean on this crutch of like saying how
many jobs you didn't book and I want to
talk about why you do that all right all
right all right all right let's go back
but anyway um but I've had to because of
the youtubers there was a time where I
had to go do their shows mm-hmm you know
and I've done a lot of youtubers shows
yeah and in my head going why the fuck
am I here yeah you know but I've had to
learn to collaborate with people I mean
and in retrospect
and that's the difference between us
mm-hmm and someone like Martin because
we in this new day and age because of
the internet and all we all have to kind
of have to do things with each other I
said so which is honestly such a fucking
relief I think it took me so long
because basically my career every time I
figure out how to do something the
business changes and the skill I had
becomes obsolete this has happened I
mean three or four times I finally
figured out how to make a network
television show never television goes
away okay and then I find my third
special where I'm like this is finally
like material that I feel like I know
who I am like this is solid special and
it's between HBO Netflix and I'm like
HBO you go HBO yeah I tape it within six
months no one can find HBO
no one knows everything I'm on Jimmy
Fallon he's I'm like in my special
nature he's like I'm on Netflix I'm like
no it's on HBO like I kept fucking up
and I kept like I didn't get on
Instagram till like two years ago
you know like so I've just stopped like
every time I figure something out things
change but I do think there's something
such a relief about like you know just
being able to collaborate with our
friends and tag each other and help each
other because it used to be you would
like pray that 50 lawyers at a network
would like you yeah you know I mean
these are people that were either trust
fund kids that whose parents you know
put them in the business or people that
came from law school that are now
creative executives pray that they like
us and that we check a bunch of boxes
and test well in like Las Vegas in
Houston yeah he's like weird testing
things I think a lot of America doesn't
even know about how shows get tested
yeah and then you have to pray that
you're gonna be the show that they pick
to put promotion behind and then you
just have to rely on a bunch of people
that have no stake in your success yeah
it's so funny that you said that because
when I was I finally went to Montreal
last year for the first time that's so
funny I thought it was and when I got
there I'm like I'm here oh it's nothing
anymore yeah the idea of comedy
festivals is like YouTube like why would
you fly six hours to go eat shit in
front of your agents yeah that a weird I
the four I'd never got new faces I never
had any of that stuff me either
I didn't get there were shows that all
the comics would get there was one
live at Gotham 140 comics got it didn't
get it drove to Brea put hair extensions
into audition yeah didn't get it yeah
didn't get a premium blend was a little
bit I wasn't quite yeah I didn't get a
half-hour
everyone's getting half hours I did the
roast and did a deal and was like you
guys have to be you got an HBO special
that was later that was way later
you don't want you HBO came to me right
now for as much how would you well
really yeah it's it's a lot of it has to
do with just just the crew the credit
yeah the credit is beautiful yeah you
know it's like no one saw my Tonight
Show back in the late 90s right but I
remember no one ever said it great yeah
I could maybe a couple comics but it was
the feeling that I did it it gave me a
sense of confidence yeah I went from
open my curtain and overnight I think
yeah in my mind yeah but here's the
thing about you I think we all none of
us can see ourselves right
you've been famous since I've started
comedy oh my god yeah your fucking mom
no why would I famous where you
Koreatown inside oh boy where since I've
known you and then I also toured Bobby
was basically the first comment to take
me on the road why are you upset no no
no that's how we listen to take me on
the road I saw how the audiences react
to you I see I used to bring you up
every night at The Comedy Store I see
how people go apeshit for you it's
always been from my point of view you
have always been famous you have always
been in the top echelon of comics I've
always had you know what I'm gonna have
a little confidence here and not do this
low sell the same thing and I want to
say that I am I've always had a cultish
a following mmm-hmm
yeah so I've always liked since MADtv
I've never had a day job yeah you know
I've always been able to survive but I
think what happens in our business it's
like tortoise and hare 101 every now and
then someone from our grade will fucking
catapult to fame and then comparatively
we're all of a sudden like well I'm only
on MADtv and touring and selling out
clubs in hilarious every night and and
doing two movies a year and
person's a movie star but everyone that
has catapulted to fame since I have
known you has fucking crashed and burned
it is miserable and has like gotten
weird like fillers and yours just
fucking killing it you just like
honestly had the most like consistently
built me you know it's thank you for
saying that
and I'm gonna accept it great and but
you know it's funny because I think at
the end of the day staying like this
even though it looks like a straight
line yeah there is a little bit of a
tilt on you Bobby
slowly think about also the way that not
to like bring God into this but people
like you and me if we got fucking three
movies in a year and like we're doing we
would fucking go insane we're not cut
out for that shit it's not healthy for
us yeah you know what's addictive
personalities are you gonna bring
spiritual saying a lot of the things
that I think we you know comparison is
the worst form of violence against
yourself a lot of times when were
comparing ourselves to other people we
don't even really want what they have
we just want to hurt ourselves policy
genius there's only one thing humans
aren't great at its predicting the
future just take a look around
no amount of crystal balls fortune
cookies and tea leaves could predict the
world we're living in right now they
wrote this specifically for our podcast
that was very catered to us I feel
attacked
but unpredictability is also what keeps
life interesting the trick is to enjoy
the ride without worrying about what's
around the corner I like this company
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze and minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find your best price you can save
fifteen hundred dollars or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies the only reason I'm
not getting life insurance is because I
feel like Benton already wants to kill
me don't want to give him more motives
but you should do it and once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and red tape for free so
if you haven't found a play-by-play
breakdown of your future inside a
crystal ball or a cookie that's okay be
prepared for anything with life
insurance a few minutes you can find
your best price and apply at policy
genius.com
policy genius will always
the future wrong better get life
insurance right right Benton this is an
intervention please get better help you
get better I can't with your mood better
helpful assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist please you can start
communicating in a 24 hours yes that's
why you should get it it's not a crisis
line not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online
available for clients worldwide you'll
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video hour phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room oh I
hate those waiting rooms with all the
yoga magazines out of here
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed so you don't to go through an
uncomfortable breakup with a you know ya
better help possessive therapists been
there better how about you to start
living a happier life today does it
better help.com / Whitney you couldn't
have said that more miserably better
help wants you to start living a happier
life today I'll never know at that time
I was serious but you should visit
better health calm / Whitney that's
better help a TLP and join the over
500,000 people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional special offer
for good for you listeners get 10% off
your first month at better help calm /
Whitney you know you know I believe you
know I believe in God and I believe that
a lot of people are gonna walk well I
believe in a sense of some sort of you
know
I don't know if I'm like if my Destiny's
Edge toonstone of whatnot but I've
always had faith that especially in the
last six months that I'm exactly where
I'm supposed to be and I feel it from
you it's there is a definite like shift
in your energy it's like you know when I
this is sound so cheesy but when my dad
died you know my dad used to beat the
shit out of the family my mom and I were
talking last week and she told me this I
never might remember this story where I
had been enjoyed us and I was 6 years
old
we lived in like a nine stories on this
apartment building in Minnesota and I
was about to die I was dying and my mom
and my dad were pulling me my my mom
wanted to take the elevator my dad want
to take the stairs and I remember my dad
just dropping me and this going and
hitting my mom in the mouth and then her
bleeding right and then I remember my
dad picking me up and take him and then
they put a needle in my spine at the
hospital but I remember that whole 24
hours being just a nightmare but that
was a constant you know mean thing in my
life of just violence all I saw was a
violence and so when my dad died in
August I really had to deal with this
trauma and whatnot and so by dealing
with the trauma and doing EMDR and going
to therapy and doing all the things work
I'm so Burgin as well I am I'm just like
far more grounded and present and I feel
like a fucking Mack truck has been
lifted off my shoulder yeah I've been
carrying around a you don't know this
but before I dealt with this trauma
every time I had a bad audition I would
go to the my car I would take a bottle
of water that big and I would hit myself
over the head over my head about a
hundred times until I bled into my face
and I did that once a week I would
punish myself for making mistakes it's
all based on you know how I was treated
as a kid and whatnot and it you know
insidiously has entered every aspect of
my life in terms of the way I so even
all those little things where I after I
do a set night you know and all that low
self-esteem shit that I do you know I
mean it's all based on some sort of
thing that happened as a kid and so I've
been trying to get that shit out of my
life and and we've never really talked
about that which is that what we were
talking with earlier every for 14 years
I have been doing stand-up for quite a
bit yeah we've known each other for
every night for 14 years five nights a
week I would say I would watch you pace
up and down the hallway go house fucking
disaster why am I do I'd watch you like
quit comedy in your head yes truly every
night yeah and then go on and destroy
that's not you don't get to weigh in on
that you haven't you don't know the
truth in terms of how well you do as a
stand-up none of us do Bobby
destroys okay and I saw this for 14
years it's nothing like the math was on
my side in terms of watching you go
through this self-flagellating thing and
I think for the long time I was like
this is none of my business
everyone's got their own ritual
everyone's got their own process it's
obviously working for him and this is
back when I did think you had to be
fucked up to be funny because before I
was in recovery and then after my dad
passed I had a couple habits that you
know I just needed like permission to
lift them and I just I saw you one time
doing it and I was like don't metal this
is so your mothering your micromanaging
your martyring this is none of your
business you're gonna fuck up your
relation with Bobby don't say anything
but it felt so clear to me that this was
not Bobby it was some other programming
it was someone else's voice it was like
an inner bully and that had no right to
be there and was actually just not true
if you were bombing every night I
wouldn't said anything I'd open like a
you probably should be nervous
it just was so in Congress with like and
for me I just was like let me experiment
with just maybe he just needs permission
maybe he just needs someone to go like
you don't have to do this anymore
because also it was confusing because
when you would go on and kill I think
there's a certain point where our low
self-esteem actually turns into bragging
when you get successful so your your
perception of yourself hasn't caught up
with your success mm-hmm so you go home
and a bomb and you go kill him it's like
fuck that guy yeah is that your version
of bombing yeah yep
hating yourself actually seems like
bragging yeah and I had someone do it to
me
Ron Funches great lovely nicest slur the
greatest just best mm-hmm and we were in
a hotel together randomly in New York
gross the London area having filthy sex
we were doing something like show
together I don't know we went in that we
ran into each other at the gym and take
a picture together I post it
and this was like four years ago and the
caption was like at this angle you can
see my crooked tooth or something like I
had to self deprecated in any photo I
took of myself I had to like point out a
flaw something like that and I posted it
and he just went why do you do that like
yeah and I was like oh no it's like
funny and you're like yeah it's like
obnoxious Wow and so he literally said
him he goes I know girls that look up to
you and your self effacing like it's not
doing what you think it's doing yeah and
I got it right away I got it
that's what you did to me and I think I
was just my ego was not present I didn't
feel attacked
I wasn't like you're jealous or whatever
childish defense mechanism I got it
right away I just needed someone to tell
me I just needed permission to shine
that sounds so corny yeah I needed
permission to not make myself small yeah
we both grew up environments where we
had to make ourselves small and that's
what you did to me back the stage what
did I say I just was like you got you
just basically said you don't I'm done
with that you basically said that I did
I go what he's like
you just killed and I'm just I can't do
this anymore with you you're better than
that I don't know what you're doing
something like that because I think it
was first of all no one had ever called
me out on it and it put me at first I
was like fuck you I thought about it for
a month they did I would lay in bed and
think about it and go yeah why do I do
that what is that no it also just like
wasn't it's also just not true I know
it's insane do you know to me it's not
insect to me it was just sort of like
you have worked your fucking ass off
like and I think that we're at this
place where pride we have to be shameful
about being good at what we do and
you've worked so hard to be good at what
you do like that aftermath of shame it's
just like the only reward we get is that
time at the Comedy Store that hour the
comedy star to have that me toxified
with our dad's old fucking nasty
narratives from three generations
like it's just like you're not welcome
here yeah you know but you know would
have it you know but even though when
you did that because you did that years
ago like a year and a half ago it you
know it had it took my dad dying for me
to even even understand why I do that
right and so by doing the work now it's
like it completely changed my life in a
completely different way I'm well aware
of my behavior and I always ask myself
why are you doing that why are you
thinking like that even the other night
when I came up to you cuz I I don't
really go up to a lot of comics for
advice maybe you that's it think of
anybody else I would get really advice
from because I know that you're you're
familiar with my history you're familiar
with the 12 steps you know mean and and
they're all I know how the business
works you know how the business works
cuz you just yeah and I and I know that
you give great advice so I am so I'll go
to you for things and and you know even
what would the thing I was complaining
about which is like I get out and I'm
gonna say this out loud and this is
gonna sound really crazy but sometimes I
get jealous yeah
sometimes I'll Drive by a billboard and
go what the fuck right sure because you
know there's skill level yeah right and
then you start going what is it it's
like it's not personal
yeah it's that personal Bobby but I can
personalize it by going what did you do
for you to not be up there in that
shitty movie that you want yeah and so
it's like that's your dad in the back
seat like how come it's not fucking you
yeah yeah meanwhile you just drove here
from the house that you just bought by
yourself okay I'm just saying but I am
it's just it's a mirage yeah it's a
hallucination it's yeah it's meaningless
it's meaningless but to me I just have
to walk through it and I also we have to
delineate like you know it's so
interesting what you said about like the
aftermath of when your primary caretaker
that kind of installed all your
programming passes like what is them and
what is you because there are times
probably beating myself up and I'm like
that's not me that's my dad that's not
me I don't think that about myself but
then there's other times are like you
know what that is me
and that's a fair criticism you know I
have to really delineate but also some
of these feelings can be Alka Mies in a
positive way I have written some of the
best things I've ever written because
someone got a special that I didn't
think deserved yeah and I fucking use
that jealousy and I use that anger to
like slam out something I think that's
healthy too I think some of it is a
little help I think you have to just
figure out a way to like shape-shift it
into something positive there's there's
something as playful competitiveness yes
you know and I and that you know when I
was um I was on a show last year with
Jenna Fischer and Jenna Fischer was like
sitting there one day with a bunch of
like scripts she's auditioning for yeah
and I go Bertil I looked at her I go hey
you're on a show you're on a show I
starred in the biggest show of all time
you're a movie star yeah yeah but she
got humiliation never she goes Bobby I'm
just I just like being competitive it's
not it yeah that's what she said
oh and it's like it's not a jealous
thing I just it's you know it we're in
it you know - believe it or not we're in
a business that's we're competing
against each other yeah and there's a
healthy way to do it and so I kind of
went oh yeah huh
so there's something healthy about it
too and also I think for me because we
know I'm in a program as well like
feelings are not facts right and we will
blow something up and put emotion all
over something that absolutely
you know does not deserve it but I try
to get down to the math so how many
comedians do you think into an hour
what do you mean like how many an hour
on stay an hour of stand-up of a lot how
many how many comic can do an hour on is
it a lot yeah I I would say probably a
thousand comedians thousand in this
country thousand can do an hour on stage
a thousand I would say 250 250 thousand
do you know how many comics are in the
country there's 40,000 calm ok let's say
how many in LA in New York oh there we
go who are like getting things all
getting through are in the rotation who
you're competing against 12
it's not that many how many networks are
there 70 70 yeah yeah people really
aren't doing that well that's the point
most of the people you're jealous of are
failing Harvey you're right so I do
think that we magnify that one that one
billboard that's up for a week we think
about it for eight months the show has
been canceled we're still jealous yeah
yeah you're right you're right and it's
also like I've had successes as well
I've been it when I see those billboards
yeah I'm in suffering yeah you know me
so it's not as if that person that's on
that billboard is happy you know there
could be suffering as well yes it does
you know what you look at that billboard
and go yeah fix it that's me
didn't fill the hole you can't one
billboard Waianae I remember the first
time I got a billboard my first thought
only one one too many a million not
enough are you one a bill but right now
with a dog that's Olivia Munn and thank
you oh is that really so mushy driving
by it real quick ago Whitney I mean
probably I mean but you never you're not
you've never been on the Billboard I had
one for a charity but I think there's
one right now that's pretty ubiquitous
with Olivia Munn and a dog I think you
look alike Wow
but yeah I don't think so but that was
my first feeling I fought my first
special economy central I wonder who was
running it at the time I thought I
literally said I want a billboard
I've never negotiated anything I was
like I don't even want money I want a
billboard
I literally set it Steve smoked at CAA
can corroborate I said and they were
like that's like a crazy and I wanted a
billboard cuz I wanted people to know
like it was like some weird old and I'm
sure it was my dad's inner monologue
gone why are you on a billboard because
you can be in a million movies but
not in LA go well where's the billboard
yeah you know I mean because you want a
billboard I think I'll tell you why in
my opinion why I would want one because
their comics see it not only that is
theirs so I was on a splitting up
together and I was not on any of the
billboard news about a family and I beg
them if you're gonna put me on a
billboard can you put it on the Warner
Brothers that you know on Barham yeah
yeah so everyone figures everyone's
stuck in traffic out and I want my
enemies to see it that's the point of a
bill you'll be just you know be a second
serving that they have me on the side i
building like this yeah gonna be like
whatever this poses yeah yeah it's so
sick huh and I remember asking for a
billboard I didn't get the cuz there's a
Comedy Central run right above the
convenience store next to the Comi start
they picked up I wanted to me I want the
I wanted the Booker at the comic store
to see it to get me fucking spot did you
know this is all strategic you know that
like every studio they strategically put
billboards around like Adam Sandler they
put a billboard on the corner of where
his house is of his movie so that you
know I mean they know where celebrities
live and they put him a lot right the
rock all the posters are on near his
house but then you drive to receipt
others not so and that's the other funny
mirages about a billboard as you see a
billboard of yourself and you're like
well these are like everywhere like no
there's one not across America yeah yeah
but yeah it doesn't work it doesn't work
yeah and you know what else I loved one
time this kind of changed my life when I
heard this Bill Murray was on Howard
Stern and Howard said it seems like you
hate being famous you know like why
don't you like being famous and he said
my advice to people that want to be
famous is get rich and see if you still
want to be famous Oh what you actually
want us to be rich ah it's not the fame
you think you want the fame yeah Fame
and money don't command at hand yeah I
was known before I had money yeah which
was even weirder I was like on Punk'd I
don't like an MTV show people recognized
me and I was in debt yeah MADtv you what
we got 4500 dollars a week crazy and
then people were like I can't
you know so I thought that was an
interesting thing so now when I'm like I
want that thing I want that thing I'm
like you know what no I don't I want to
do that corporate gig Tampa yeah and get
that corporate gig money and put money
in the bank yeah you can I say something
what this is gonna sound so cheesy but
this is what changed me I think so when
I went to when my dad died and went to
pcs this place and I yes it's a metro
pcs PS P I don't know what it's called
but um it's a psychology place PSC and I
was there for a couple weeks and I was
still using drugs and psychology you
know I you know that we were talking
about being mindful and about living in
the moment in one session or whatever
and I this is so so cheesy and when I
walked out of that therapy session I saw
for the first time life in HD like I saw
the world you know and I walked by this
pink bush and there was like these
little leaves and these the leaves look
like spiders because of and and and
these little hands were trying to fight
to to get on this thing and I said I sat
there for like five minutes looking at
this bush in and I had a spiritual
awakening Wow that I've really felt for
the first time in the moment and
grounded and and just really looking at
what now is mm-hmm right and by doing
that it's changed every how I feel about
myself when I wake up I don't feel like
you know I mean there's a truck on top
of me I feel just so light and um you
know it's it's sad to say that it took
my dad to die to get there but you know
in in retrospect it's sad that he's gone
and I miss him
much but it is like cloud over us like
our primary caretakers if it was
negative is a cloud I mean when my dad
passed I didn't do anything for I took a
year off like I was just going to like
animal rescues and like hanging out with
wolves and rescuing bees like I was so
lost because I realized everything I've
ever done is to get his approval
that was my engine and now he's gone and
I just felt very aimless were you in the
room when he passed no oh wow no well
what happened so did you go see him
though it was kind of freak he had both
my parents had strokes like in the same
year oh my god my dad was in ICU like
outside Savannah and he couldn't walk or
move any of his body and so I wait I
visit him like a bunch of times but then
he passed and it really fucked up like
freak like obscene awful like way and I
knew right away what you at his house or
at a hospice he was at a hospital and in
this particular one healthcare in
America as maybe you heard it's not
great and at this facility in the south
if you have a child who is mentally ill
you know schizophrenic bipolar and
someone can't care for you they just put
them in nursing homes with elderly
people oh there was just an accident
yeah oh wow it was like a I mean there's
it's kind of wild because to me he went
out the way he lived what the fuck what
this doesn't even add up this does you
make sense like I've never heard of this
there's no way to prepare for this like
everyone was like we don't even know
what to do the logistics were so crazy
and the whole thing was so unbelievable
that it did kind of anesthetize the pain
and shock cuz there was just like
instantly having to deal with logistics
alright which is the overly high right
and I don't think I'll ever process it
yeah I think it's always gonna be like
on a shelf what did he do growing up he
wasn't physically abusive though now or
psychological my dad actually you know
what's interesting is I could older you
know the more I obviously have so much
compassion for my parents and
forgiveness for my parents and true love
for my parents because I do it stake
ten years and a 12-step program - I
truly say this this is not like some
brainwashed shit or like what I would
say to my sponsee is to keep him coming
back is like I truly think they did the
best they can and probably better than
they were capable of Wow
once you really understand how addiction
works I understand that my parents
fucking overcame neurological sort of
they overcame neurology to show up for
me like the fact that they showed up for
me at all like my dad he would forget to
pick me up from school like the fact
that I got to school like that's how I
look at it now you know like I mean it
has taken doing you know third step ten
step every day for 10 years but I'm
literally like I look at my childhood
now cuz I coming in the program it was
so dangerous I used to like take pills
that I found on the ground I almost died
when I was a year old I put like a pill
in my mouth had to go to the hospital
like you know dropping things you know
my sister and I would run away for days
at a time nobody would notice like we
were in so much danger all people in the
house like random like really dangerous
shit and I went in the program I'm such
a victim my life was so hard I would
share stories about my childhood in a a
double winners and al-anon meetings and
people would gasp yeah like it takes a
lot to get some you know oh my god yeah
my dad used to sing a song to us before
we got out of the car he'd go who do you
trust and we'd go no one no way it's the
funniest there you go who do you trust
and we go Daddy
trust no one was his motto Wow and then
he would tell us that motto and then
wouldn't pick us up from school we like
don't trust anyone
does anyone then he wouldn't show up but
then he would show up every now and then
and he would do scenes from three amigos
when member wind Steve Marlow and he was
the funniest person when he did show up
yeah funniest person on the plane yeah
which makes it even more confusing for a
child and I think for me I definitely
defaulted to when he goes away it's my
fault I wasn't funny enough I wasn't
smart
I wasn't pretty enough I wasn't good
enough whatever that was just the
narrative I built but that wasn't true
now that I understand addiction yeah
so now as an adult I go oh no no I
understand why my inner child why
defaulted to that at five years old but
I know no that's not true
yeah addiction makes you hurt people you
love and that's just sometimes the
people you love you hurt the most now
that I understand addiction I know that
none of that was personal you know what
my dad we used to do as humor you would
get drunk I'd have like a friend spend
the night he would run in my room naked
and he'd run out and he'd have a toilet
paper sticking out of his ass because he
always had totally paper in his ass
because it was so moist and he would
turn on God and he would just run out
and it would be like no no you got to
explain to your friend like traumatic Oh
your friends were over yeah just
embarrassing he's alcoholic he said that
was funny but it's just really fucking
embarrassing I'm so sorry you know and I
think about now that I understand
addiction the amount of shame that it
requires to drink as much as I saw it
just means me oh my god these people
were full just a fucking miracle
it's a fucking mirror look at with with
the stuff that you grew up with it's
just a miracle where you're at in life
but maybe to we you and I you know had
fucked up you know I mean weird things
growing up and we were able still to
come here and to you know get a career
and all it's just you know in many ways
we're resilient in many ways that I'll
say all the things that all the you know
essentially like all the armor I
developed all that what in program we
call character defects I like to call
superpowers because you know we can deal
with fucking anything people are like oh
you have to audition in front of nine
people know nothing stresses me out
I come from actual chaos yeah Jonah me
go on stage at the Comedy Store at 1:00
in the morning with people throwing
glasses at you drunk okay no easier you
know then a day a Tuesday at my house
growing up you also changed this about
me you don't even remember you're so
influential in my life you you really
are you're what kind of i sorry podcast
but you but you are years ago I stood
sometimes going to audition
would freeze hmm right and because I
would have a panic attack whatever yeah
and I came up to you one day and it was
embarrassed because you were the only
person that I even brought this up to
and I go I know it's so embarrassing I
don't know what the fuck happens I had
to get these little panic attacks and
you're the one that introduced me to
beta blockers in fact I did this pilot
in Chicago and I wouldn't have been able
to do it without beta blockers I was in
my head I was just like you know having
all these panic attacks all the time but
no beta blockers essentially just
stopped adrenalin without making you
tired so it's not like a xanax or an
ativan or something just stops adrenalin
what would happen is is that my I would
start getting sweat I get my dreadful
flow I would sweat yeah and then in my
mind I'd be like oh my god they can see
me sweating and I would shake yep oh my
god they think that I'm eating about not
I know what the fuck is going on and I
would smile yeah and then they're
looking auditions are I don't think
people really talk about this enough and
this is why would anyone books a job and
I'm jealous I'm just like you know what
if you were able to go in there because
auditioning is its own skill auditioning
and acting are two separate things and
when someone goes into books a job I'm
like honestly
hats off yeah it's not a skill that I
have I don't have it either I go in
there's five people sitting there they
probably already have someone else that
they want yeah I've been on both sides I
know you've been on both sides you know
how it works like they wrote it for
someone in mind who's reading it right
now who may or may not do it they have
nine other people they want you're going
in as their backup yeah you're going in
they've heard the scene 50 times and
some of them wrote the scene some of
them wrote they've been sitting there
for they have to pee they're hungry they
need to check the phone the person that
they wanted to play the part just had to
pass for whatever a million reasons they
secretly probably want to be in their
own show also sometimes you're in the
room like in the lobby yeah and you see
a hundred people that look exactly like
you like a nine-foot Nigerian guy it'll
say you know we're open to anybody you
know man yeah and then you go in and
sometimes they don't tell you who's in
the room you were walking in one time
and it was really famous actor in the
room and you're like oh shit and then
really
I don't care and then we review them you
don't need you don't want to like look
like you're starstruck so then you're
like hey asshole Will Smith an asshole
what am i doing and then you just start
melting down and we're comics we are
programmed to get a laugh we're sitting
and then you start going like I couldn't
find parking and then you start doing
bits and you're said why am i doing no
and best-case scenario you start killing
and then you do their material and their
materials not as funny as you yeah their
material starts by its engagements isn't
yes it is one of our producers just said
they got invited to a wedding
using Zola about freaking time Zola
makes wedding planning easier and less
stressful with the wedding websites
registry invitations and a guest list
manager all in one place so free wedding
website designs
there's hundreds of gorgeous designs to
pick from it's the highest-rated
registry side of all time register for
gifts experiences and honeymoon files
this beautiful affordable invites and
paper they'll help you collect addresses
and track online RSVPs with their free
guest list manager Zola has helped 1
million couples get married and all of
you to go to Zola dot-com / Whitney
today and use the promo code save 50 to
get 50% off your save the dates you can
also get a free personalized paper
sample before your purchase that's 50%
off
save the dates at Zola comm / Whitney
promo code save 50 Benten we're talking
about function and beauty and I think
you need to take this one cuz you've
you've just yeah I got it you're in deep
with function of beauty yeah you ready
to live your best hair life in 2020 cuz
I was what did you do I went online I
took their easy little quiz they have I
told them my hair concerns what I wanted
what I needed like what's a question
like it's like because they ask you a
bunch of questions and then they
customize very simple it's not it's a
little graphic so it says like do you
have oily hair do you what do you worry
about length or growth do you worry
about damage and you just click them
first you did pick I think up to eight
different ones then everything is vegan
cruelty-free they customize the color
you want the scent you want at other
options that they have
what do you do I did a pair a purl
having prickly pour and lavender and
yellow yeah lavender and Yeller colors
of the bottle the colors of Oh gorgeous
non-colored nonsense it if you want that
and very easy mmm but you wouldn't you
take the quiz you get 20% on your on off
on person on huh okay if 20% on your
first purchase or that I was just so
excited about the prickly pear you go to
function V VI comma slash Whitney to get
started right now you got a function
that concise yeah but you have to tell
them that they never use sulfates
parabens phenol or mineral oils or any
other harmful ingredients continue you
could a function beauty.com slash
Whitney to take your four part hair
profile quiz and save 20% on your first
order don't spend another minute on hair
misery go to function of beauty calm
slash Whitney to let him know we Sencha
Benton Sencha that's function of
beauty.com slash Whitney I was like it's
our first time with CAA and this guy
Jason Heyman yeah he's my guy he's like
the biggest guy right
and he cuz he has like Zack out from
that cuz all these guys Hemsworth and
everybody will Ferrell right so um he
goes you just have a read with a casting
director it's elgu-- only be one person
so I don't really memorize it you know I
go I'll just cold read it right but then
when I show up it's like I remember
these wooden doors these gigantic wooden
doors and they gave me a glass of water
which they never give you any water but
a glass of water
why because it was like higher up than I
thought oh oh it's like a big yeah and
then when I walked the door there's 12
people there right and camera set up
it's a test it's a test that's a thing
when you get to that when it's like
three people up for a job and they're
you do something called a test which I
was like them finalize directors there
and I'm now in my head going I can't do
it
no I don't know what No so this is what
I do know I did the worst thing you
could possibly do so
beta blocker so you you I have the first
line that's alright I have the first
line could you be the casting director
right yeah and you say go ahead Bobby
and I'm gonna literally give you the
time the timing of what I do right so
this is the real time go ahead okay
all right Bobby whenever you're ready
[Music]
and I left I left the room after seeing
by effeminately by I left I got in the
car and I started crying yeah I've done
that yeah been there I was devastated by
it I remember I was I want to say this
is like a big director I think there's a
chance Jason see this is a Jason Segel
movie I think it was the one with Mila
Kunis and Kristen Bell
I go to an audition and in auditions
there's like there's action there's like
stage direction and you never know if
you're gonna have to like do the stage
direction sometimes it's like she walks
in holding a baby and you kind of just
mime you're holding a baby or whatever
and you know it's raining out and
they're holding an umbrella you kind of
ignore that and you're like oh I'm just
gonna do the dialogue right this was a
sex scene and I was like oh but like I'm
sure we're just gonna like kind of
pretend they give me a chair and they're
like you're on top and the sexy I'm not
off book of course I'm not memorized
have the job I'll memorize it if you're
gonna pay me yeah yeah they give me the
chair and I'm also in the waiting room
and I hear like like I hear other
actresses and I'm like oh my god that's
what that was I heard screaming and I
was like I have to fuck a chair I have
to oh I have to ride a chair not knowing
the line I'm like holding a piece of
paper and you realize wouldn't you do a
sex scene it is how you fuck
you're just showing there's not like oh
I'm gonna fuck differently that's like
you know you're just gonna go into
whatever so you're basically just
showing a bunch of strangers
how you fuck man you're like try it just
was also public in your head - the whole
thing was awful the whole day and I was
like Mike I have like a mic pack put a
microphone on you and it's just like
weird yeah and this is before like women
like you know made a stink about like
getting jobs in Hollywood suppose like 9
dudes oh wow and this was a time where
you're like oh you're gonna get a job if
someone wants to fuck you you desire tip
the scale just like that all right so
not getting the job it's just extra
shitty because I just show them how I
[Laughter]
wear does also on tape also you don't
need to put that scene in the audition
yeah you do why
yeah I will get it you know I can fuck
something every actress can do yeah you
don't need to do this at 2:00 p.m. on a
Wednesday oh my god oh you did do it yes
yeah yeah I know there's a couple tapes
floating out there have you ever seen
the Chris Klein Mamma Mia video no
please look up Chris Klein Mamma Mia so
this is the only video where I'm gonna
make you watch I normally don't do this
lot the podcast it's a bad audition this
is a leaked audition oh no lasting
associate Chris Klein que le I n hanami
is not a big Chris Klein fan okay so yes
so this is a no the left one the one on
the left left left left
yes so turn it all the way up this is an
audition someone the casting office must
have released it oh this is how big of a
video it is they're selling ads on it
they should we turn it out and release
that it should be can we turn it up all
right away hey by the way you guys had
Mandy Moore in here she is an angel of
all angels I don't know if you guys saw
American Dreams
that her and I did together where I to
sing hopefully better here then I did up
there that was acting this may be
singing but she is just a dream anyway
that's my own personal fuck up
[Music]
[Applause]
it's so rape his eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's my biggest fear
oh we have tapes out there Kandra I have
fluids coming out of all my orifices
from that there's videos of us there's
no way the videos me fucking a chair is
somewhere it's somewhere in somebody's
computer this is why we don't want to
get any more famous
oh my we have to stay the level we're at
if we get any bigger are bad auditions
from the early aughts are you on
released did he work at all after that I
know I mean this was for Mamma Mia yeah
he should know better then what if
you've seen a necklace he's won a
medallion even when this agent called he
should have said you know I just can't
sing there's no way I'm gonna get this I
don't think a lot of I don't I don't
think he knows his limitations yeah he
got a job he's Alexander Payne's
election he just walked on set there
were like that's the guy oh wow do I
mean yeah he's the opposite of us I got
an audition a year ago we're like you
can you play it was an offer can you
play a Korean dude but you have to just
speak kind of fluent Italian the fuck
yeah yeah and I go can they go you can
learn I got you know what I just yeah
I'm just not my it's not my skill set
yeah I think I'm also kind of at the
point where I don't want to embarrass
myself yeah we lose way more than we
gain if we do something and it's bad
yeah cuz no cuz people look at you and
they don't go he's not getting things
are like oh he probably passes on a lot
of stuff yeah I don't know I do pass a
law yeah doing something bad
counts against you doing nothing you get
to stay where you are
yeah is that I mean I think about movies
my thing is like
doing a bad movie I might as well just
not do a movie yeah I mean I audition
last one I did was this is Marvel movie
that they want and and I went of course
I'll audition for that I'm not gonna I
didn't get it
oh you got it I don't know I don't look
that up to you we find that we always
find out eventually yes I do you know
why why because I I don't internalize
rejection anymore cuz having written
things I know it's not personal like
it's I'm not just saying that like I've
literally been like you are the best
actress that came in and you're not
getting the job happens all the time
you're the funniest person you're not
getting it because of these this litany
of things completely out of your control
you know and there's people to come in
and they're so competent and they're so
good
I remember this is so this was when I
was doing the NBC show Jaime Pressly
remember Jaime president came in crushed
the audition I've never seen anything
like it
Wow she's a fucking beast she was on my
name is Earl
yeah or whatever yeah she won an Emmy I
think yeah a couple of Me's
she came in live no sides wasn't holding
any papers Wow
comes in boom kills it I was like what
the fuck was that and it was just like
we weren't ready to make the decision
yet and we had to get Chris like it just
and we lost her and she probably thinks
she didn't get the job getting racy
Horne who I think was great perfect
because she had more of a vulnerability
to where you know the pieces fell into
place perfectly but it was sort of like
she fucking came in and destroyed it
yeah and I did not give what did you we
should be able to call them mm-hmm and
just go hey you're not gonna get it but
here's you know we haven't made a
decision but I just wanted to let you
know whatever happens you killed it
yeah yeah I think that should be a thing
I agree I also think we should pay
people to audition yes the fact that sag
is not there are actors unions not all
over that the fact that I mean when I
audition for something I put five days
into it that's how long it takes me
it's a date yeah to memorize something
oh you go in it's already been offered
to Leslie Bibb or whoever right and so
I'm kind of just like that was five days
of my life the fact I think that writers
should be paid to pitch even if they
don't sell it yeah an actor should be
paid to audition
test it for the new girl yeah right and
I remember having a road date no right I
went you know why they want me to test
me on Friday yeah
cancel the day yeah I'm gonna get an
acting coach Tuesday yeah and I'm gonna
memorize this thing inside and out I
didn't get it obviously but it's like
and then you know you and then you show
up at Fox yeah and you're sitting there
with between you and two other guys yeah
and you're sitting there and you eat the
kind of pressure yes and the nerves that
you have to fucking conquer but I think
for me if if I just knew I was gonna get
paid for this okay well you know yeah I
would be I'd be a better actor because
I'd be like I'm gonna win either way it
just takes the pressure off and this is
brings me to your point of no joke
basically kind of why I started a
podcast like Rogen was in my ear about
it you know Andrew Schultz was in my ear
about it a little bit but you said
something that like blew my mind because
something happened like a year we love
each other like a year ago year and a
half ago
mm-hmm somebody start happening where I
realized everyone at the comic store was
there for you I was like what's going on
like I'd be like this next guy you've
seen my MADtv and people are good and
then I started noticing people were
wearing tiger belly shirts like in the
audience said I was just like what the
what happened here I've done this
podcast but you know and then you like
got that show on ABC with jenna fischer
and then you're getting all these movies
or something i was like dude what's
happening in your league dude I'm
telling you doing the podcast is why I'm
getting all this other stuff in
Hollywood and I was so fascinated by it
because my question for you is do you
think it's because Hollywood people
listen your podcast and have more an
awareness of you or do you think it's
because you have your own thing going on
you need Hollywood less so you can
gravitate the right things and not give
off a needy vibe you know thanks for
having me on your podcast I think it's a
combination of all yeah I think that um
here's what it is is that I was stuck in
this MADtv sketchy yeah and of a thing
and what the podcast did was
people don't like me because I'm doing
characters or I'm silly it's because I'm
authentic ly myself yeah and they're in
love with who I am yeah rather than oh
he's that guy that did funny characters
on the show which I I honestly I miss
everyone at MADtv and this Ike and
Jordan and Keegan and everyone I work
with there I was the greatest experience
of my life but um it put me in a
pigeonhole a yeah of course and what
Tigerlily did was I got my audience
tripled or quadrupled yeah and these are
people that come up to me and they go
hey man I got sober because of you uh-oh
or hey man you know I'm sorry about your
dad my dad died and we can talk on that
level and they're not necessarily fans
or just people that are my extended
family so weird to say in that way and I
think that also because the industry
looks at numbers yeah and they look at
the numbers of Tiger belly and they look
at like here's this guy who's in his
late 40s who's been in this business for
a very long time he's obviously not
going away because I kind of reinvented
myself in a weird way it's like you know
I can't really tell you I think it's a
combination though but I do think yeah I
think it's it shows like sort of it's
it's interesting because you get stuck
in this thing where I think it happened
me with sitcoms or people like she's
like a sitcom girl it's like well I
can't prove to you I'm not that unless
you give me the chance to break out of
it so it's like you know they want to
pigeonhole you but they also won't give
you the chance to surprise them and grow
you know but but this also there is a
bit of a fear too I think the industry
is there's a fear because now if you Joe
Rogan told me I don't fuck with
Hollywood you know he his business is
probably bigger
- Marvel movies then Hollywood at this
exactly his business is saying yes right
he's a complete utter franchise he's
podcast a hit show hit if you and I made
it to be sure right now if it got five
million views of be a runaway hit yeah
biggest show of the fall hundred and
nineteen million downloads a month yeah
yeah yeah I mean that's it's more than a
hundred giant Carson of our time but
it's also go Johnny Carson wasn't glow
he's global as well yes and it goes into
sports so it's it's just it's a it's
it's incomprehensible but it's mark as
well mark you know has carved out a
piece of that but then now we're all
doing it yeah and we were all people
that fucked with Hollywood we're all
people that did sitcoms and did move not
only fuck with Hollywood like begged to
suck Hollywood's dick meg I'm begging
you to give me less money than I deserve
you ride this is podcasts also help me
understand holy shit all that money was
going to them yeah I didn't understand
how much advertiser money they were
taking meanwhile we were getting paid
whatever 30 grand an episode which is
obviously a lot of money but based on
the amount of money they're making yeah
it's nothing how much they were under
paying actors for so long so now like
it's pilot season right now right and
it's like what's what it's so funny I
get the email you have an audition for I
don't want to say the name but yeah if
some pilot right and I'll just delete it
oh man I don't even I won't respond to
it you often offer me the job yeah I
don't respond to it I don't know where
it is I don't I don't even read it I did
recently put myself on tape for a movie
that I think I got really close on but I
will put myself on tape from my house
yeah that's what I'll do or I'll
FaceTime with the director if it's if if
obviously if Tarantino want to be more
seen of course I'll read a thousand
times or Cesar whatever right of course
but you know to do a TBS show and the
iron gu Carson you know me I'm not
reading gooky Gerson you know via the
irony is those the kind of people that
don't make you do that like Scorsese
just fucking hired Jim Norton to play
Don Rickles mr. honey see audition I'm
Martin Scorsese I will make it good I
know what I know how to make you oh wow
that's perfect - I don't perfect her
fasting yes so the irony is the best
directors don't need to put you through
that because they're decisive and they
know they're gonna get what they need
yeah and they trust their own taste yeah
I mean when when I remember when
Sebastian was flying to New York to to
audition for Scorsese right but
Sebastian was
stressed out about it because he was
just like it's just he's only there for
me yeah and we're just working on the
scene no and I don't get it yeah I'll
just go make 40 million dollars right
right on Arenas yes so you you have to
have something else going on it's such a
great metaphor for everybody in all
parts of your life if you need something
too badly if you if you chase something
you chase it away yeah the more you want
something the more you're telling them
that you don't deserve it and you're not
going to get it and then you end up
repelling it maybe just our cry yeah but
you know what a blessing yeah you know
it's a blessing finally you know it's
something that like is easy to do I'm
okay I'm good at it very good very good
at it and I can do it from my house I do
with my friends and I also the kind of
people that like me out there are people
that I would hang out in a heartbeat I
was just in Chicago and that's if that
is such a great way to put it is the
world and people are so fucking scary
all the time you never know who you
aligned with who you vibrate with your
crowd are people that you would be
friends I was in Chicago and this girl
just on Instagram and this this guy this
white girl in this Asian dude or dating
and their fans at Tiger belly but
they're photographers as well and they
just said hey check out her stuff and I
looked at it I liked it and they're like
so you want would hang out I go yeah
let's to take some photos they just pick
me up in the hotel room we went ahead
lunch I went and did a photo shoot with
them that's so cool he dropped me off
I know like there's no weirdness I know
a lot of people that because of a
caricature they do or a persona they do
hate their fans
yeah and that I imagine is the worst
possible to be no I love my people
that's why it was like after the shows I
do a meet and greet I meet every single
person I don't charge anything I just
want to take a photo talk them you know
what I say thank you so much for
listening and it's like it's the best
yeah and to be able to perform and do
your thing and not be consumed with
shame after
like is this person happy is this
producer happy you only have to respect
am i proud of that yeah I don't worry
about anyone elses ego are we gonna get
picked up for another season do they
like me does this pur because also when
you do a TV show you whatever you
provide to it
you can leave with pride or shame or
whatever and then for the next six
months you're waiting for feedback are
you gonna come in for reshoot so you're
gonna come in to do voiceover because
you fucked that thing up and then it
comes out and you have to wait for the
ratings and the ratings come in and then
the next week you wait it's like you're
just auditioning for approval from just
every no more
did you know Shane Gillis who was that
again the guy that got fired from SNL oh
yeah yeah yeah what did you think that I
didn't mind it I thought that it was a
podcast he did years ago it was I said
not a good podcast right it was like not
a lot of views or whatnot you see a lot
of things in podcasts yeah I have said
you know I said something on a podcast
once and I got in trouble for it really
yeah I said that and I don't know why
sorry open let's rehash it no cuz I've
been talking about it I talked about
before by well I'll say it I just said I
don't know why I said black people are
oily I don't know why I said it I said
it was there was no there was no
maliciousness actually would have been
worse what a she would have asked yeah
yeah
you know I didn't say I just said that
yeah okay and then what happened was um
what happened was a lady a black lady an
african-american lady excuse me what'd
he say Bobby I got an email from this
lady and she goes if you don't send me
$15,000 I'm gonna blast this to everyone
I know and I know variety and all these
fucking outlets and I go I sit in on a
podcast yeah I emailed her back I go I
said on a podcast like it's already out
there yeah it's just like yeah but
listen you know it's people are really
talking but I can really make people
talk about this and ruin your career
okay so then she kept doing it and she
I'm not I'm not fucking around and then
check this out this is the craziest
thing Wow
so I Jordan Peele calls me and Jordan
goes hey he didn't say we're not oily he
didn't say that he goes you know you
guys a me and Chelsea are getting
married we're doing a commercial for
booking.com we want you in it and I go
how much it was an exorbitant amount of
money and I go how many days of work one
it's me Eugene Lynch a bunch of people I
go yeah let's do it
so I'm on set you're not gonna believe
this I'm laying next to Jane Lynch
because her and I have a kissing scene
in this commercial and these executives
come up to me no I'm sweat I can't do
can we talk to you for a second I'm
leaving and I go what yeah we need to
talk to you outside for a second and
they take me outside these suits like
booking.com
coming yeah yeah yeah ad agency people
stuff yeah and they go did you see black
people were order yeah no this woman she
tracked down your commercial producers
yeah what happened after that so I go I
didn't say that like that I said that
nigga we heard it we heard you say it
and I did I did say you caught me then
they go we already knew you said that
before you did the pub then why do you
ask what we're just telling you that
some lady is threatening to sue us
what yeah for having you on this thing
just to be careful so then I called CA
my agents and at the time CA had Bill
Cosby
so so at the time that Bill Cosby in
that and Bill Cosby was in some legal
trouble
you know they we go but we have a team
could we had to create a team for Bill
Cosby legal team a team of people that
will crush this woman so yeah see they
crushed that they silence this woman and
I never heard from her again but black
people aren't oily it was just a joke
yeah it was years ago yeah yeah it was
like three years ago but it is wild I
know you believe but it is wild how
you're able you talk shit on your
podcast if nothing else this is a huge
endorsement for the tiger belli podcast
because he will talk some shit I'm not
talking shit just tell that you tell
these fucking it's like Howard Stern
shit how he used to like just go for it
like everyone is so afraid of getting in
trouble everyone's walking on eggshells
and look at when TJ Miller was on my
podcast we talked about dude you guys
talking about Michael Bay's not gonna
hire me no I think you're fine you
didn't hire me oh he already did the
thing yeah just be in a weird way no but
I'm just saying there's so many people
in this business that are fuckin
monsters and nobody has the balls to
talk about it and it just so fun yeah
yeah I mean it's listen I you know I had
a director two weeks ago who screamed at
me the whole time that's crazy and I
remember thinking to myself I'm not
kidding you I show up in Hawaii first
day of work to do magnum p.i and the
director comes out to me and he goes
don't fuck this up you can't talk to
people like that and he walks away and
I'm like I'm going oh fuck it's like
that oh so this is actually crazy to me
I was on a set like this recently -
there's executives I'm like how is
no-one yeah how are you it's so a
charred nightmare how are you guys
allowing this not for me maybe five
years ago I'd be like just as a it
absorb it and just get
fuck it I'm gonna talk about yeah I have
a hit fucking podcast I said his name
I'll go fuck yeah and if you if you want
to come Peter and do my podcast let's
talk about yeah you know I mean part
like your that's not me calling anyone
out he did that because here's the other
thing it's also I'm a fucking grown up
yeah you can't talk to me like yeah you
know when I was 22 like okay I'm paying
my dues like I'm your equal
I'm not a bad guy I'm not trying to hurt
anyone's feelings but it's like no not a
fucking bitch and I'm not I'm not a
tampon and you can't just use me also no
one's harder on me than me yeah you
don't already have I already am yelling
at myself yeah I don't need your help
beating me up over here yeah so you know
listen I honestly I've had I've been in
some movies and I've worked with a great
like I love Larry Charles yeah Larry
Charles is so cool I've done like three
or four things with him I've worked with
a lot of great people and I walk away
from pretty much every set work with
making friends and and I'm I'm listening
I like to listen and I want to learn and
sometimes I fuck up but it's like if you
scream at me yeah yeah no no no I treat
me like that
it's also you're fucking in my car it's
also a crazy time when you realize I'm
the healthiest person on this set
everyone else is in doing the work we're
doing those people aren't in a fucking
program they're being run by their ego
in their insecurities and their dad's
fucking the way their dad talked to them
they're still talking to people and just
like you don't get to do this yeah like
the answer's no because then I leave
with my self-esteem corroded yeah so um
that's I think also what pot taggable is
done that I can now use it as a place
yes you can alka my's everything it was
for nothing
yeah and use it and get that ad money
yeah so tiger
it's super-awkward
[Music]
[Applause]